Well then there's food,
Cole Cole,
who I have no respect for by the way,
I think.
I think I've read a fair bit of full
cool and I think everything he says is
obvious.
So for example,
he criticizes the idea of mental illness
as a,
as a social construct.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
obviously,
I mean it's not like psychiatrists and
psychologists and mental health
professionals who are relatively well
informed,
haven't known about that since for the
last 60 years.
I mean it might be a revelation to
people who who don't notice that psyche
psychiatry for example,
is something like a compromise between
the patient biology and the social
world.
You know what I mean?
Psychiatric ailments often have a
biological tilt,
but the way they manifest themselves in
society is clearly conditioned in very
intense ways by the particular
conditions.
Obtaining at the point that the person
who has that biological predisposition
exists even whether or not that's
pathological can be tilted one way or
another by the cultural norms.
And then of course,
when you're dealing with issues like
insurance payment and treatment and
hospitalization,
obviously you're pulling in all sorts of
systems that are by no means purely
scientific,
but I don't find it particularly useful
critique.
It's obvious as far as I'm concerned.
And the other thing that the code did,
I mean I think this is the typical,
especially the French intellectuals,
typical sleight of hand.
Once Marxism became,
you know,
once you were no longer able to call
yourself a committed Marxist because
committed Marxism had led to
unbelievable brutality,
you know,
on a scale that had never,
probably never been experienced in the
entire history of the planet,
at least in terms of its reach and
duration.
You didn't get to call yourself a
Marxist anymore,
although there were still people and you
still see them saying,
well that wasn't real Marxism.
Which I think is a cop out of staggering
proportions.
That usually means,
well,
if I was the person running the country,
that wouldn't have happened.
You know,
that's the logic behind it.
They didn't put the principles into
practice properly.
It's like,
yeah,
well lots of people put the damn
principles into practice and the same
thing happened everywhere,
so at some point you have to kind of
wonder if there's something wrong with
the principals.
Anyways.
What Fico did was take the Marxist
presupposition that everything was,
could be boiled down to economics and
economic power and translated it into
the idea that everything just boiled
down to power,
you know,
and the reason that we have institutions
is to include and exclude and that the
institutions always run for the benefit
of those at the top.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
that's a little bit true,
but it's,
you know,
it's,
it's a scientist would look at that and
say,
yeah,
well probably,
you know,
power dynamics in a,
in a functioning economic and political
system,
maybe account for 10 percent of the
variant,
something like that,
maybe 15 percent.
So for example,
if you have a say you want to go to an
ivy league school while if your parents
went to the school,
you're more likely to get in,
but you're not that much more likely to
get in.
And you still have to be,
you know,
roughly speaking,
what happens is that if you have a
pretty decent,
you know,
high school gpa and you do very well on
the sats and you have some other talents
of some sort because that's also
necessary.
Then they might pick you over someone
else who's roughly will you qualified if
you have a familial history of
attendance at school.
So obviously you get an exec and an
advantage,
but it's not.
It's not the kind of advantage that
accounts for the entirety of how the
system is structured.
It's an advantage.
While you can say,
well that's not fair.
It's like,
yeah,
okay,
fair enough.
Most systems are certainly not 100
percent either.
Fair or just definitely not,
but you know,
instead of comparing them to utopia,
you might compare them to another
system,
which is the only reasonable way to do
it.
It's like everything looks terrible when
you compare it to the best thing you can
possibly imagine,
but the best thing you can possibly
imagine is it's an empty fiction because
it's so devoid of detailed content that
you can't use it as a guide to reality.
Now,
I mean the idea that things could be
better has its roots in in some sense,
in a broad scale Utopian project and I
believe that things could be better,
but that doesn't mean that when you're
doing an analysis of a complex system,
you get to compare it to an ideological
utopia and then describe all the reasons
that it's bad.
It's not appropriate to do that.
It's too simplistic.
You're not going to do anything to
actually address the problems that the
system has.
If you take that approach and then of
course like pure utopian thinking is
extraordinarily dangerous because if you
think that your way of molding society
into some ultimate state of perfection
is headed towards some ultimate state of
perfection,
then you can justify absolutely anything
you do right now on the basis of the
fact that things are going to improve so
radically.
In the future,
and that means any of your behaviors are
excused.
The end is worth it.
Well,
if someone says that you have to kind of
wonder what they're actually planning,
excuse me,
what they're actually planning to do.
So.
Okay.
So,
well,
what's the issue?
Well,
the issue is that it's so the same
critic with regards to Food Co.
He said,
you know,
it's basically the same thing that food,
coal criticized a variety of low,
you know,
profound institutions,
sexual institution say like marriage and
then institutions of power like prisons
and institutions of um,
mental health,
you know,
the whole institutional framework.
He criticized them on the basis of power
and exclusion and you could do that and
there's some truth in it.
But you know,
food,
coal also made the presupposition.
The problem with that presupposition is
that everything is about something else
is that it's almost impossible to see
how it can be applied to fuko himself.
So you'd have to ask if you were a
student of flintco,
what power aims drove his attempt to
analyze everything in terms of power.
And I actually think with google it's
pretty obvious.
So,
but it,
it's a game that never goes anywhere.